so [ __ ] Island's one of those movies
that lived renfree in my head even
though I'd only watched the film a
handful of times after picking up the 4K
Blu-ray and revisiting it for this
breakdown I found a lot of incredible
details and hidden things in it that
seeped into my subconscious on the first
watch and this really elevated the movie
far beyond the appreciation that I had
for it originally Scorsese has really
crafted a master PCA and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down why
the film is so haunting we'll of course
also be talking about the ending and all
of the clues that build up towards it
now I was someone who guessed the twist
in the first scene on my first watch not
to brag but the idea it was all in
someone's mind is a trout that's been
used in a number of films and shows like
the Twilight Zone Fight Club The
Machinist and so on however even though
I think he can safely guess it in the
opening scene the film actually goes
beyond the twist due to its complex
characters and narrative even the title
itself is layered with [ __ ] Island
being an anagram of Truth and lies if
we're really reaching it can also be
rearranged to say Ted Hunt's lion is
with DiCaprio's character going under
the name Teddy Daniels this is later
changed up to become Edward Daniels and
we discover that he's actually called
Andrew latest which is also an anagram
of Edward Daniels later on when we meet
latest we can see that he has a giant
scar across his face that also goes
through his eyebrow one thing that you
might not notice is that Teddy also has
a cut through his eyebrow and this was
given to DiCaprio by the makeup
Department to symbolize that they're one
and the same and what I appreciate about
the ending is that this isn't a movie
where it pulls the twist out of thin air
at the end and instead it's telegraphed
to us in multiple scenes we start off on
a bow rather than a dock which is where
we see Teddy meeting his partner Chuck
you think that they would meet on the
shore and the fact that it's here shows
that this is where the game begins
rather than Teddy being an actual person
Chuck is later revealed to be Dr Shin
and this is actually given away subtly
during a moment in which the pair both
interview a patient
tell me about him
what's he like
oh he's uh
look at this again and she glances at
Mark ruffalo's character upon the
mention of Dr Sheen Zen is actually
filled with lots of little details and
behind both the patient and Teddy we can
see two Gods when we go to the shots of
Chuck there isn't anyone standing God
behind him because as we know he's a
doctor and not a patient and one of the
best moments in the scenes when the
patient goes to take a drink from a
glass of water he raises it to her mouth
but if you pause the frame and look
closely at her hand you'll see that
there's actually nothing there we then
get a quick cut of her putting the glass
back on the table which is when the
fantasy continues water is very symbolic
in the movie as we learn that Teddy's
wife drowned their children which is
what causes mental psyche to break down
this is why it's important for the
character to start up on a boat and
we're first introduced to Teddy being
sick he says
and water is very much the first test to
start off this quote-unquote simulation
it's later removed from the patient did
not trigger him as we can see how
devastating it is for the character here
now another thing that you might notice
about Teddy is that he has a Band-Aid on
his head because we call him
elastoplasts in England which I'm not
forced out on you my American viewers
don't you worry about that the thumbs
Up's right there anyway this
symbolically also represents the guilt
that he's repressing now the entire
situation he's concocted in his mind is
very much a metaphorically placing a
Band-Aid over the guilt he carries over
killing his wife come the end of the
movie It's removed showing how he's
faced up to the trauma and has taken
this away another nice touch when we see
Teddy throughout the movie is that his
clothes don't actually fit him this is
something I only really noticed on this
watch through as I always just assumed
that it was the style at the time
however if you look at the other doctors
in suits you can see that clothes would
have been tailored and then being
ill-fitting on the characters shows how
they will likely just grab the rack so
that they could be worn as part of the
role play now in the background we can
hear the music thumping away and it
might surprise you to learn that
absolutely no new music was composed for
the film every single p used in the
movies from a library of scores released
in the 30s to 50s at scorses he pulled
from in order to add atmosphere well at
this extends Beyond just being nice in
the background and due the nature of the
film but very much all being an act by
the Asylum it definitely adds to it I'm
sure everyone watching this video has
played make-believe at some point in
their life and they pretended to be
someone that they're not I used to think
I was James Bond and had pretty much
hung the theme tune in my head the
entire time when I was doing it it was
about two years ago I'll be honest and I
think the musical choices here represent
the same thing this is all Andrew
playing along and this score being
pulled from the films adds to his
perception of it now I am going to be
calling him Teddy for the most part just
to stop things getting confusing and it
is important to bear in mind that they
are indeed the same person Chuck asks
him if he's got a girl and we then see
flashbacks of his wife Scorsese plays
with us during the scene and we get a
cut to the water before getting a freeze
frame out of here
foreign
she died this of course symbolizes how
she drowned their children and the
freeze frames almost a mental block put
in place by Teddy to stop him from
seeing the connection Scorsese uses
freeze frames in a lot of his movies the
director often does this to make sure
we're paying attention to the scene
Teddy then says his wife died during a
fire which of course is very much the
opposite to water now this shows he's
concocted the complete opposite story in
his mind in order to save himself from
the pain bio is very important in the
movie as well and this is shown to us at
several points we discover that Dolores
set fire to their apartment as a way to
end her own life which is when they
moved out to the lake over its usage
goes for beyond that we see Teddy
smirking throughout the bomb but
cigarettes and lights are always given
to him by someone else Teddy doesn't
even have his own pack which is
highlighted to us in this opening scene
cigarettes oh yeah
and the fact they're always lit by
someone else is also done for a specific
reason inmates wouldn't be allowed to
run free on the island with a box of
matches or a lighter and therefore these
are kept away from Teddy whether he does
later get his hands on some when he goes
to visit George nice
now it's possible that this is even a
hallucination by him as he Sparks One up
but it disappears when he gets to the
bars he seemingly lights up another one
but this triggers a hallucination of his
wife standing in the corner Bayer also
gets a major focus in two key scenes
later on now the first is when Teddy
seemingly finds Rachel solando in a
Cliffside cave who watches the fire
dominates the shot and it takes up a
large part of the frame as the two talk
however we can see that Teddy's hands
are still shaking and they'll Infuse
cigarettes are blamed for this I don't
think that's true we know from the
ending that he's not being drugged and
this this is suggesting that the fire
isn't actually there because it's not
keeping him warm now a fire also plays a
big part with Dr Jeremiah and it appears
in his vision with latest later on
therefore I believe the fire is all in
his mind and the water represents the
reality whereas fire represents the
illusion that he's given to himself this
is why the lighthouse where the
Revelation happens is surrounded by
water and even Teddy's mission to escape
means that he has to go to the dock
which is of course also surrounded by it
juxtaposing this later sits in front of
a fire and Teddy of course says his wife
died in one when in reality it was all
connected to water now Beyond this I
also think that the storm is fake too we
have a weird point where he wakes up and
we're told the storm has passed but we
still see a flash of lightning there's
also the damage that the storm does
throughout which destroys trees and
parts of the Asylum we visit the
Courtyard at one point which looks worse
than the YouTube comment section with
trees scattered everywhere once the
truth is revealed at the end though we
can't see any of this there's no way
they could have fixed this also quickly
when they run into the storm we also get
this line from the guard
nice night which I think you've taken
literally shows this could all be made
up therefore I think the storm simply
used as a narrative device by the
doctors to keep them confined to the
island storms are of course symbolic as
they of course bring water with them and
this could very much be washing the
island of Teddy's delusions now upon the
shore we get another clear clue that
something is off this happens when the
gods all stand around menacingly looking
at Teddy with their guns drawn
[Music]
foreign
this is at the start of the experiment
and then naturally apprehensive that he
could go well at any second always seem
a little on edge Mr McPherson right now
Marshall we all are now upon reaching
the Asylum they're asked to hand their
weapons over Chuck has some difficulty
drawing his from his holster and instead
he just hands out the entire thing with
the gun inside of it Chuck is supposed
to be a US Marshal that would have
likely drawn his weapon several times
but the fact he can't do this again
hints to something being off with him
now in the garden we get a patient that
looks at Teddy and she does a shush
motion this could be a case of air
basically Henning out what's really
going on however it could go far beyond
that bits wallaby on Reddit theorized
that she herself had a lobotomy and this
can be seen by her missing hair she has
a large scar across her neck bloodshot
eyes and something just seems off about
her these are all signs of a violent
patient and yet she's allowed to wander
around the garden with tools that could
easily be used as Weapons the only way
they'd allow her to do this is if she'd
been lobotomized and the shush motion
could be done to warn Teddy that if he
doesn't keep quiet that he could end up
like her now at this point we meet John
Corley played by Ben Kingsley the other
way he's presented can make him come
across as a villain he's actually the
good guy in all of this he set up this
elaborate scheme to try and cure Teddy
rather than going with the lobotomy
which the other doctors were suggesting
apparently they're here to catch Rachel
solando who we get the backstory filled
in on she killed all three of her
children
she drowned them in the look behind her
house she also believes this place is a
home in the Berkshires to sustain the
delusion that her children never died
she's created an elaborate fictional
structure and she gives us all parts to
play in that fiction again signing back
to the idea of anagrams we see at the
end that Rachel solando changes to
Dolores Chanel AKA Teddy's wife or
Andrew's wife and what about the husband
he died on the beaches of Normandy she's
a war Widow now we also hear that her
husband died during Normandy and we know
that Teddy helped the liberate a
concentration camp during the second
world war which also added to fracturing
his psyche he says sanity is not a
choice and this could be heading towards
a choice that Teddy makes at the end
I've always been someone who thought
that he was well aware of the monster
that he was and that he decided to spare
himself of a pain but we'll talk about
that more later on in the video now
Rachel was apparently locked in her room
but she managed to escape by seemingly
evaporating through a wall this again
hints that she doesn't actually exist
and in her cell Teddy finds it out under
a dislodged tile a lure of 4 here of
course refers to the names being
anagrams and patient 67 is later
revealed to be Andrew latest AKA Teddy
we even get a doctor admiring the law of
four later on and how clever it is
showing how he's in on it kill salando's
no the law of four I love that research
then begins on the Bluffs and here we
see some of the guards just sitting
around doing nothing this is because
they know that Rachel doesn't exist and
that it's pointless searching for her
Teddy also asked what the lighthouse is
and the God says what's in there more
patience sewage treatment facility
now Teddy is seen as one of the most
violent offenders on the island and the
sewage treatment facility could be the
god basically saying what he thinks of
the guy who's gonna end up getting his
final stage of treatment there we let
alone from noise that this is where they
carry out the lobotomies so the line
shows what some of the staff think about
the criminally insane now from here they
question the orderlies uh well is that
is that is that Tommy from Power and
much like how the patient gave away
Chuck was Dr Shin we see the nurse doing
the same thing when she's pressed on him
yes Dr Sheehan led the discussion
Dr Sheehan
yes
he's Rachel's primary she glances at
Chuck both times again showing who he
truly is I'm told Sheen left on vacation
that morning on a boat and is of course
did a lap and then brought them back to
the island Teddy orders that they try
and contact him however the storms
apparently destroyed the lines on the
mainland again showing how the storm is
used to keep things centralized to the
island the operator here is clearly
playing along and when the trail leave
we can see him turning around almost as
if to check it's okay to drop the ACT
they then go to cauley's house and we
see a record playing his two showed up
at the start when Teddy was thinking
about his wife and it's something that
later appears with the Revelation with
the same song being used
[Music]
with God
it's also something that he saw in the
concentration camp the fact that Teddy
suspects Dr Jeremiah is a Nazi is a
sliver that ties back into his time
during the second World War Nazi
scientists of course carried out
experiments in the concentration camps
and the doctor represents everything he
hates interestingly this piece is Gustav
mala's piano quartet in a minor this was
actually banned in Germany during the
war due the composer being Jewish this
could be chosen for that specific reason
with it showing the contradictions that
exist in the movie Jeremiah also says
you have outstanding defense mechanisms
this is true as well as Teddy's able to
concoct this entire fantasy to defend
himself from the truth he psychoanalyzes
Teddy and says that he's a man of
violence which he would only really be
aware of if he knew the character
beforehand now when they go to sleep
Teddy has a dream about his wife who
very much tells them the truth he does
this throughout all the hallucinations
and here she says that Rachel is here
this is signifying that she is her but
the way we're meant to take it is that
she's still on the island water starts
to see from her abdomen along with blood
and this was the location where Teddy
shot her Teddy wraps his arms around her
and this moment resembles the painting
in the Kiss by Gustav Klimt she also
tells him that Andrew latest is here too
which cows a double meaning that sends
him up on his quest to find him now from
here they start questioning the patience
and the first one brings up a glass of
water
then she asked me if she can have a
glass of water they also speak with Mrs
Kearns who I believe is actually a
friend of Teddy like him she killed her
partner and she seems to want to protect
him when asked if she knows Andrew
latest she gets up and walks out and she
also writes run in the character's
notepad the fact that she does this
makes me believe that they were close
and that she was trying to warn him
about what was really going on look at
her reaction with this in mind and I
think it becomes clear that this entire
scenario is breaking her heart
did you ever meet a patient named Andrew
latest
no
never heard of her at this point Teddy
and Chuck head out and the former admits
he requested the case because Andrew
latest lit the match which caused the
fire that killed his wife he slowly
stung to pieces together and they headed
the graveyard as it's the one place no
one would notice a body being hit Teddy
tells Chuck about what happened when he
reached the concentration camp and we
learned that he and his platoon gunned
down the guards that they were supposed
to arrest I'm gonna ruin this scene
because it was ruined for me but when we
go along the gods right at the end you
can catch one on the floor smirking
before he then plays dead I bloody hope
you're blacklisted from Hollywood you
ruined the movie
a paranoia starts to see Bane as it's
revealed that Teddy was gonna blow the
lid on the experiments that were being
carried out on the island thus he starts
to suspect he was brought in by the
shrinks to get him so that he could stop
everything getting out the fake Rachel
is presented to them and you can see the
reactions by the characters as they
start to figure things out and 42
patients and Wards A and B which means
there's a total of what 66 patients at
this facility
that is correct yes
love the little smirks they do here
almost nodding along like he's finally
figured it out Rachel talks about how
she drowned her children and after
telling the story she starts to act like
his wife both shadowing the anagram
reveal now that night Teddy has a dream
that he sees Rachel and her child
amongst the camp victims the child
stands up and says that you should have
saved us all this represents the girl
that Teddy feels over not taking his
wife's mental issues seriously she told
him about it but he brushed it off and
this eventually led to their deaths your
sees my man Casey Jones playing lettuce
who lights up a match and holds it to
his face he is the delusion and the
match being held up this way continues
the idea that he's the embodiment of
this Rachel arrives during this and
shows in the mirror of their children
and dolorosen comes in and Teddy says
his line why are you all wet baby
there's actually foreshadows this line
later on why are you all wet baby this
then pays up at the end in one of the
final scenes we get baby
why y'all wet now the next day they head
into the restricted Ward and they're
approached by a God who does this upon
leaving all right get your asses moving
then go on
this is such a creepy moment and it
might even make you think that an inmate
has dressed up as a god however in
hindsight he clearly finds the whole
game hilarious and is laughing at Teddy
and how ridiculous this all is
eventually he then comes across noise
who gives the entire game away this is a
game all of this
I'm not investigating anything
you know [ __ ] retina maze very
obvious one but but I were just being
thorough now this is the first time that
Teddy's been allowed on the island
though and it's important to bear in
mind as to why noise doesn't keep up the
illusion here nice directs him to the
lighthouse and both he and Chuck end up
heading out to it Chuck seemingly takes
up all over the edge though with his
body lying on the Rocks below this is
later washed away by water symbolizing
that it was never real the thing that
pulls him back into the illusion is the
fire from the cave which is where he
meets the quote-unquote real Rachel she
says you were a nurse
I said Dr Marshall this is clearly her
commenting on her actual role and why
she's been given such a high profile
role in the illusion she's bowed stuff
about how the island is secretly trying
to build super soldiers through
brainwashing people and removing parts
of their brains so that they feel
nothing that morning we see Teddy asleep
and there's another flash of lightning
even though there's no storm again
hitting at things being off picked up by
the warden my man Buffalo Bill spouts up
about violence he tells Teddy that he's
as violent as they come upon making it
back to the mainland we see the patience
being out that Teddy interviewed earlier
they are clearly pointing at him and
even the gods tell them to stop looking
at him so that they don't give the game
away listen closely for sure
for sure
they clearly say stop looking at him and
Coley says that someone got so wound up
by noises stories that they beat him up
a couple of weeks ago this is revealed
to be Teddy and we discover later that
he called him latest which is what broke
him now it's reveal that this exercise
has been carried out before with Teddy
and it worked but he regressed which is
why they're trying one final time Corley
also says you don't have a partner
Marshall you came here alone and Teddy
then showers very much representing the
cold reality that he's just been given
he wants more runs into Dr Jeremiah who
fumbles with a needle in his hand though
it seems like they're trying to drug him
because he's exposing what they're
potentially doing this is actually
because he's terrified Teddy might
lashette Teddy believes her Chuck has
been kidnapped and that they're using
him in the experiments he then sees a
vision of Dolores and says that he wears
a tie because she gave it to him but
that it's ugly nice way to say thanks
for the gift he ends up using it to
destroy a car once more shedding a part
of his past the fire washes over his
wife and daughter but they don't die and
thus it wants more hammers home the idea
that this element represents an illusion
before it blows it sees what's
apparently Rachel's daughter and she
walks over to Dolores this is actually
her child and this is another clue that
it's the pair who are related Teddy
Dives in the water before swimming to
the lighthouse and this is very much a
baptism Forum that reveals the truth
Corley then starts to bring everything
to light with Chuck revealing that he's
actually his doctor the pair want to
avoid the lobotomy as they think that if
the pair come to the revelations of what
they've done on their own that they'll
be able to heal themselves without the
need for surgery Teddy oh oh well Andrew
we'll call him that from now to stop the
confusion Andrew grabs his gun and fires
away which makes it seem like the doctor
was hit the fantasy keeps it for a split
second but it fades and the gun is
revealed to be a toy Andrew has then
shown the corpses of his children
including his daughter Rachel who he
dreams about nightly she tells him that
he could have saved her and this is the
final thing that makes him realize the
truth but watching the scene play out we
see Andrew shooting his wife he wakes up
in a scene similar to The Wizard of Oz
everyone is around his bedside including
the nurse who played Rachel originally
we learned that Andrew created these
fantasies because he couldn't face up to
what happened with his wife and also
their children he blames himself for all
of it because he refused to get his wife
help and it seems like there's finally
been a breakthrough what about one way
or another Andrew wants to hide the
truth from himself the initial
regression was carried out because he
couldn't face up to it and realizing
that he'll now have to live with it I
believe that he plays up the fantasy
once more so that he's lobotomized when
he sits down with Dr Sheen he says to
him that he has to go back to the
mainland and calls him Chuck it's a
heartbreaking moment and watching the
performance that Mark ruffler gives here
really carries the scene just the subtle
nud of the Dark Death tells us so much
and we see the defeat wash over him as
he realizes his more gentler tactics
have failed Andrew then says this
which would be worse
to live as a monster
I want to die is a good man
and it's a line that I think will haunt
everyone who sees this movie I think
it's sad to Chuck to let him know that
this kind of approach worked however he
cannot live with himself and it's just
too devastating he willingly walks
forward to his lobotomy and had he
really been in the fantasy I don't think
the character would have carried this
out but it's what Andrew wishes to do
and we end the film with a shot on the
lighthouse summing up his fate it's
something that stuck with me since I
first saw it I hope you've enjoyed a
retread through the movie and all the
clues in it obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the film so make sure
you comment below and let me know I know
there's people who think Teddy does go
back into the fantasy at the end rather
than being a choice so let me know below
what you think as there's a hell of a
lot to talk about now if you want
someone else to watch then make sure you
check out our Brighton Memento which
will be linked on screen right now it's
really great in-depth video going over
everything in the movie and hopefully I
see you over there right after this by
the way I've been Paul this is the heavy
spoiler show and I hope to see you next
time you take care enjoy 2023 all the
best peace